foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday November 15th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
after years of arguing against
regulation a lot of people in the crypto
industry lately have been pushing for
oversight with a lighter touch but the
crisis at FTX has put plans for some new
crypto legislation on hold
according to wsj sources the Senate
agriculture committee which oversees the
federal agency that could be tasked with
regulating crypto has scrapped a
tentative plan to mark up its bipartisan
crypto bill this week a bill that had
been drafted with ftx's input at the
same time Regulators are expected to
increase their oversight and
investigations of crypto firms hoping to
give investors in the space a little
more security joining us to discuss what
this means for the sector is our
reporter in Washington Paul Kiernan hi
Paul hi Zoe Paul can you start by
telling us a bit about what was the
point of the crypto legislation that the
Senate agriculture committee was looking
at and what was in it and why were they
considering it
so at a high level the Senate
agriculture committee bill it's called
the digital Commodities consumer
protection act or the dccpa what it
would have done is it would have given
the commodity Futures Trading commission
jurisdiction over Bitcoin and ether and
probably a few other cryptocurrencies
the cftc as that regulator is known is
the smaller of the two Market Regulators
the bigger one is the Securities and
Exchange Commission and it does not have
any rules in place currently that it
could really
use to regulate these markets and so one
thing we know is that if this bill were
passed it would mean several years of
rule writing efforts by the commodity
Futures Trading commission to like build
this regulatory framework for crypto and
of course during that time the crypto
industry would be heavily lobbying the
cftc and Congress and what would the
bill have meant for other crypto tokens
besides Bitcoin and ether there were
various versions and drafts of the spill
circulating but it would have preserved
the ability for the Securities and
Exchange Commission to say wait no that
looks like a security that's in our
jurisdiction and go after crypto
exchanges for listing crypto tokens that
met the definition of a security Now one
reason the SEC didn't like the CCPA
is that it would have deferred to the
crypto exchanges in a first instance for
determining what type of asset a given
crypto token was so this would have
given crypto exchanges like FTX and
others the power to decide whether or
not something was a security or a
commodity something that usually
Regulators get to do
yeah right I mean theoretically it
wouldn't have given the crypto exchanges
the final say the SEC could still come
in and second guess their decision but
it would have deferred to a certain
degree
this distinction to the crypto industry
again there were various versions of it
that were circulating and tweaks being
made and so you know a final version of
the bill is not in existence because
they haven't voted on it there is an
expectation that Regulators like the SEC
will step up their oversight of the
industry particularly given what's
happened at FTX how do we expect that to
play out for the past year the crypto
industry in Washington has gotten a lot
more organized with lobbyists and
spending and the result of that has been
more and more lawmakers Republicans like
Tom emmer Democrats like Richie Torres
many more repeating crypto lobbyist
talking points one of which is the SEC
should not do regulation by enforcement
rather than enforcing the existing laws
the SEC should provide more regulatory
Clarity to the crypto industry to tell
crypto companies exactly what they can
do not just what they can't do the SEC
has maintained for several years now
that the laws are clear that there is a
really pretty straightforward test as
called the Howie test that determines
when something is a security and when
it's not and the crypto industry is just
trying to kick the can down the road one
upshot of the FTX implosion is that it's
going to push the needle towards
enforcement let's take a moment to talk
about the investigations into FDX who is
looking into them right now and what are
they looking to find
yeah so the SEC is investigating FTX
they were frankly investigating FTX
before this happened but the
investigation has lightened in the wake
of the collapse they are looking into
whether FTX listed unregistered
Securities whether it's lending product
constituted an unregistered security
more recently they've been looking at
the interconnectedness the links between
ftx.com which is the global Exchange
ftx.us which is its U.S subsidiary and
Sam bankman Freed's trading firm
alimator research we've reported that
FTX The Exchange lent customer funds to
elevator research which is generally
forbidden what other crypto related
investigations have we seen the SEC and
you know other agencies carrying out and
what do we expect the impact of those to
be it's hard to say at this point we've
reported that the SEC was investigating
Finance coinbase which is a publicly
traded company as well as a crypto
exchange has disclosed that it was under
SEC investigation for like various lines
of business SEC chair Gary Gensler wants
the crypto exchanges to register as
National Security exchanges
there's a number of reasons why they
don't want to do that and why that would
be difficult but he has expressed a
willingness to work with these companies
to try to get them registered there's
some risk if the SEC were to file a
lawsuit against the crypto exchange
particularly one whose finances aren't
audited and publicly disclosed there's
some risk that it could precipitate
a collapse or that it would like a cease
and desist order might cause the
exchanges customers to lose access to
their money and so
I think that from the sec's perspective
the best thing would just be to register
all these companies and get them to
comply with the law but Gary ensler said
if they don't do that if they don't make
any Headway and there's nothing public
that has come out that suggests there's
a lot of Headway being made the SEC will
bring Enforcement cases it'll sue them
all right that's our reporter Paul
Kiernan thanks for joining us Paul
thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
head over to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks so much for listening
foreign
[Music]